opening statements are expected to begin
this morning in Bill Cosby's sexual
assault retrial the first child for the
80 year old comedian ended last June
with a deadlocked jury five new accusers
could take the stand this time the
defense is also expected to present new
evidence claiming accuser Andrea
constant tried to extort money from Bill
Cosby
Jericka Duncan is at the courthouse in
Norristown Pennsylvania that's outside
Philadelphia Drako good morning good
morning before we even get to those
opening statements the judge will hear a
defense motion to actually remove one of
the jurors after he was allegedly
overheard saying that he thought that
Bill Cosby is guilty now right now the
jury is made up exactly the same way it
was in this first trial with two African
American jurors seven of them are men
five are women comedian Bill Cosby
smiled and waved to fans outside the
courthouse during jury selection the
jury could hear up to five additional
accusers in the retrial including
supermodel Janice Dickinson last year
jurors failed to reach a verdict after
Andrea constant testified that Cosby
drugged and sexually assaulted her
in 2004 but Cosby says the interaction
was consensual accuser Lily Barnard
won't testify but she will attend Cosby
denies Bernards allegations that he
assaulted her in the 90s Barnard
believes the rise of the me2 movement
will help jurors better understand
Cosby's accusers and what the meeting
movement is showing is that it's
perfectly normal for survivors of rape
and sexual assault particularly those of
us whose perpetrator is a powerful
person to just be silent but now
eighty-year-old Cosby has a new attorney
Tom Mesereau Mesereau is best known for
helping clear Michael Jackson of child
molestation charges the defense is
expected to call a witness who will
claim that constant told her once that
she could make up a sex assault claim
against a celebrity to get money they
are also expected to reveal constand
reportedly received and alleged 3.5
million dollars from Cosby in a civil
suit I think that's a double-edged sword
Gloria
red represents dozens of Cosby accusers
if in fact the jury is permitted to hear
that millions of dollars were paid to
the victim they might ask themselves why
would so much be paid if in fact nothing
had been done to honor your constant now
jurors were selected from here in
Montgomery County where Bill Cosby has a
home in the last trial jurors came from
Allegheny County about three hundred
miles from here if convicted
Bill Cosby faces the rest of his life
possibly behind bars Nora all right
Eureka thank you